welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
and still sinning you probably recognize
this disco anthem
[Music]
well why I'm saying by the British
people has been the soundtrack of
weddings bar mitzvahs and pretty much
every drunken night I had as a teenager
or recently it's become the unlikely
soundtrack of Donald Trump's rallies in
America
[Music]
thank you
so do the Trump
actually quite a Nifty mover but the
group has now threatened to sue Trump
over the use of their music and I look
like band that played at his muralago
estate without their permission they
argue that fans now believe the real
Village People are endorsing Donald
Trump and they threatened well basically
go to Legal war with him
so there's a long list of artists of
argument they don't want to be
associated with Trump in the past and
I'm joined now from Atlanta by the
British people's Victor Willis and by
Maga rapper Forgiato blow who's in
Florida but welcome to both of you
thanks to Lewis uh thank you very much
indeed for joining me thank you Sarah I
feel like a part of my a part of my life
has just appeared on screen so thank you
for all the entertainment over the years
thank you Mr Morgan how are you doing
I'm great thank you now your wife Karen
I believe is leading the legal battle
with Donald Trump over this on behalf of
the band what is your problem with
Donald Trump using your music and and
look-alike bands and so on
well first of all let me again thank you
for having me on the show
um
as far as Donald Trump is concerned let
me say that the president Donald Trump
um I like the fact that he likes my
music
um
as far as him using playing the music
um I asked him a long time ago not to
play the music but but at the same time
legally he has a right to play it I mean
anybody can play that wants to the
particular problem came along When
Donald Trump decided to have some people
who dress up like Village People right
and have them at Mar-A-Lago performing
to uh the song that I wrote and it was
singing
and it made it become a situation to
where I got a lot of calls and a lot of
emails from people and fans Etc that
were like really upset by the fact that
they thought that we were endorsing
Trump and this is where the confusion
became to where my wife who is the
manager of Village People at the same
time she's a Juris Doctrine lawyer uh I
myself am the original lead singer and
writer I wrote all the songs YMCA Macho
Man Etc in the Navy and
um we were bombarded by a lot of fans
that were were upset by the fact that
they thought that the people that were
performing that marlago were actually
the Village People I got it you know
whereas Village People we're not we're
uh we we stay out of politics we're not
a political group we do not we wouldn't
endorse a trump and we wouldn't endorse
a Democrat okay
I got evicted let me go to Forgiato so
this is not really an anti-republican
thing for the other this is basically a
we want to stay out of politics
altogether thing shouldn't that be
respected if if for these people one of
the great bands in the world you've
entertained the world if they just want
to say look we don't want to get
political at all shouldn't they have
that right
no I don't think in the world right now
I mean
we have a platform and we're teaching
you know the new generation which Trump
is also putting on their song I
understand they don't want to be
political bouncy it's a problem I mean
there's five to eight-year-old girls
around the world dressed up by their
favorite princess singing Frozen are we
going to stop them from doing that every
single day I don't see what the problem
is I just feel like it's an attack on
Trump anything Trump does people say you
know Trump is above the law he's not
he's under the law they go out Trump for
everything
um so I just think it's an issue I don't
think that's a problem I think he's all
right well let me ask you a question all
right what's been your biggest hit
oh my biggest song isn't actually a mega
song it's called vanilla Sprite with
Rick Ross and Vanilla Ice
um but four more years probably my
biggest song but if Joe Biden or BLM or
any type of organization wanted to play
my music I really wouldn't care that was
going to be my question so you you
wouldn't mind if Joe Biden did that at
his rallies your song no because Trump's
not being negative playing it he's got
to dance he's making everybody in
America especially this America we're
living in right now happy again you know
making America
doing the negative he's he's being happy
he's not I could see if he was being
disrespectful to them they know their
Legends
let me bring Victory
come back in let me interject here thank
you sir number one uh young man you have
a misconception of what I just said I
said we do not mind Donald Trump playing
the music because we don't care who
plays the music he has the right to play
the music as much as he wants that has
nothing to do with the particular
situation uh we would not we would not
be saying anything as a matter of fact
YMCA with him playing the music went all
the way back up to number two on the
billboard something that I wrote over 40
years ago so it is not a problem with
him playing the music matter of fact it
helped us as a group The Situation
became to where we had to put the cease
and desist out when he had people dress
up in our costumes and perform at
Mar-A-Lago which gave a lot of the fans
the impression that it was us as Village
People endorsing him as a political uh
idea okay let me bring in Forgiato to
respond to that I don't think nobody
thought the endorsement was going to
make a difference in what's going to
happen in this election I feel like
karaoke is not illegal people dress up
on Halloween we're going to stop we're
going to cancel Halloween people I mean
they're they their group they're dressed
up he's sitting as a police officer you
got constructed was he the first police
officer ever to be a police officer was
there in the first construction
I have a I have a confession to make I
actually went out let me finish I
actually went as Donald Trump
I do sorry I'm I'm running this
interview I actually went dressed as
Donald Trump to a Beverly Hills
Halloween party
so I didn't get his permission so I'm
kind of sympathetic to that but did you
get sued did you get us did you get a
cease and desist about it not yet Trump
um
Trump gets a lot of hate from people who
don't know physically Metro Trump's a
nice guy great guy I've never seen
another negative in person about him I
just feel like it's they have a great
song they have a great music okay
okay let me another happy note Victor
how much money have you made from yes
sir how much money have you made from
YMCA
well I've sold over 100 million records
over the years wow um so I can't so I I
mean you know I've sold quite a few
records
Etc again it was it was the fact that no
we get it we get it yeah but I think
these are the ones that approached that
started bombarding me with the fact of
of seeing uh somebody dressed as Village
People but you know I know what they did
they didn't pick you know if it's a
here's a thing they were doing it as a
tribute to you I mean there's actually a
different way of looking at it as
Forgiato says which is it's kind of
flattering isn't it I mean there must be
Village People tribute acts all over the
world you can't go around so well you
know if they if they had announced it
that that you know there are several
tribute groups that that perform I mean
you know if it was announced that here's
a tribute group to the Village People
performing my two-man or whatever it
would be nothing to say I got it I mean
I got it
I think we're going to clarify to we'll
clarify to president Trump if you
introduces them as a tribute Act is fine
but if he tries and passes them off as
the real thing that can only be one one
Village People and only one Victor
Victor Willis and what an amazing star
you've been and the happiness you
brought to people in my generation and
many more but particularly mine because
my teenage years lit up with your music
they said it's a pleasure to have you on
the program and you Forgiato thank you
thank you so much thank you both very
much I appreciate it Trump 2024 let's go